Yay summer!
Yay!
Woo!
[Laughing]
Ohhh
Yeah!!
[Laughing]
Back to school already?
Too bad we can't have Summer
forever.
There it is our new school
New classrooms.
New subjects.
I feel a stomach ache coming on.
There's a special test you can
take, if you pass it
you never have to return to
school again.
Yay!
This isn't going to end well.
Today we are studying the
television.
Oooo
I told you this teaching stuff
was a piece of cake.
it's easy when you make it all
up.
Potato yum
Huh?
I think you mean potassium.
Ah!
Is that going to be on the test?
It takes a lot of courage
to admit when you're in over
your head.
We students might not always
give you teachers
enough appreciation but in my
eyes you're all heroes.
Here you go Ms. Offmar.
This should get you through the
next few months.
Hey Snoopy, page thirty-four